sziasztok a következő vendégem bándi
domokos domi a kükülő étteremnek a séfe
akiről mindenféle érdekes dologról
beszélgettünk például arról hogy
mennyire komplexis egy séfnek a munkája
hogyan áll össze egy étlap valamint hogy
hogyan jutott ki az idén tavasszal az
olimpiára úgyhogy tartsatok velünk és ne
feledkezzetek el
[Zene]
feliratkozni köszöntelek téged a
műsorunkban domi a ked séfünk a vendégem
most bándi domokos és mindenféle érdekes
témáról fogunk beszélgetni köszöntelek
szabi köszöntöm a kedves nézőket a
kedves hallgatókat örömmel jöttem egy jó
kis beszélőre én alig vártam ezt a
beszélgetés rengeteg kérdést írtam össze
valami egy egy egy olyan terület amiről
tipikusan tanulhatok és szeretnék is
tanulni mert mert ez egy végtelen a a az
az akármilyen szűk mezgyének tűnik maga
az étel és az ételeknek a világa mégis
számomra egy ilyen végtelen mélységű
valami és és számomra egy ilyen rejtély
is úgyhogy vágjunk bele ebbe a
beszélgetésbe olvastam egy pár cikket
rólad és ebbe a pár cikkbe nagyon
érdekes életutat írtál le ugyanis
érettségi után te
villanyszerelőként tanultál hát nem
igazából elektrotechnikát tanultam igen
de viszont már 10 osztályban rájöttem a
arra hogy nekem ez a a reál tantárgy
mint például a matek a fizika a sok
képletek számolások áramkörök nem az én
világom tehát azt hittem hogy ez engem
igazából érdekel de amikor egy kicsit
nagyobb betekintést nyújtottam hogy mit
is jelent tulajdonképp a villanyszerelés
akkor rájöttem hogy rossz útra tévedtem
tehát dolgoztál is akkor pár hónapot még
villanys még azt sem azt sem mondhatnám
hogy dolgoztam mert sikeresen
leérettségiztünk és utána én bontogattam
a szárnyaimat hogy
én kézzel fogható szakmát akartam
választani nem gondolkoztam tovább
tanulásban vagy az a az egyetemen hanem
kézen fekvő kézzel fogható szakmát
szerettem volna én magamnak és akkor
bontogattam a szárnyaimat dolgoztam
például nyári vakációba asztalos
műhelybe rájöttem hogy eltelt egy-két
hónap és rájöttem nem az én hivatásom ez
nem az az én érdeklődési körömet
egyáltalán nem
veszi és utána dolgoztam lakatos
műhelybe vas fémmegmunkálás az sem
tetszett akkor volt az országban egy
multicég amelyik éppen betört az
országba és
egy cégnek az al leányvállalatán
keresztül mi ennek az óriás cégnek a
belső berendezését
készítettük tetszett jó volt de még
ebben se ebben sem láttam én saját
magamat tehát nem nagyon érdekelt és ez
a cég amikor gyakorlatilag
felszámolódott akkor én tényleg a kossut
utcában zsebredugott kézzel sétáltam és
gondolkoztam hogy holnaptól hogyan
tovább
és a kossutban volt egy nagyon-nagyon
vagány hely nagyon te mindig mentem el
mindig benéztem szemmel az volt a neve
hogy ópium az egy nagyon
elegáns fiataloknak is való de nagyon
minőségi hely volt és ki volt odaírva
egy táblára hogy konyai kisegítőt
keresünk és így ahogy elolvastam nekem
nagyon-nagyon megtetszett ez hát mondtam
csináljunk egy próbát tegyünk egy próbát
én elmondtam a vezetőségnek hogy nem is
főztem sohase nem is tudok főzni
egyáltalán de viszont mindig is érdekelt
már gyerekkoromra visszatérve
én úgy nőttem fel olyan gyerekként
nőttem fel hogy anyu nyugodtan le tudott
küldeni engem vásárolni vigyem le a
szemetet rázzam ki a porszívózsákot
kavarjak ki egy majonézt hát ez a házias
éned már mut hzios énem már úgy úgy
benne mutatkozott anyú édesanyám
többször is
mondta hogy belőled szakács kellene
legyen nyilván ugye ilyen jellegű iskola
akkor annak idején nem is volt és amikor
én leérettségiztem akkor nem is
indítottak semmilyenféle vendéglátós
osztályt sem na de hát ez 19 évesen ugye
az ópium előtt gondolkozva
belecsöppentem ebbe a vendéglátásba
akkor mint konyhán úgy mint konyhai
kisegítő mint mosogató legény
gyakorlatilag és nekem már akkor első
pillanattól fogva az a nyomás az a bent
a konyhán az a az a az a mozgás hogy
miből áll össze egy gyönyörű szép
fogás mitől mosolyog a vendég és mik
azok az ételek és mik azok a fogások
amitől ő vissza is jár ez nekem
nagyon-nagyon megtetszett mikor volt egy
teltházunk millió fele kellett gondol
zni nem unatkoztál egy percet
se nekem ez rögtön nagyon-nagyon
megtetszett és akkor döntöttem el azt
hogy reggeltől esttig dolgoztunk
éjszakával végeztünk és nekem nekem ez
nagyon-nagyon tetszett ez a
mozgás szóval mosogató legg így van
szeretném hogyha kicsit végigjárnánk
ezeket a hierarchiákat mint a hadseregbe
ott is gondolom a ebben a világban is
megvannak a hierarchiák most tegyük fel
egy egy michlin csillagos étteremnek a a
belső hierarchiáját nézzük mert talán
ott a legfejlettebb ott ott van
legjobban
ki reprezentálva minden milyen mi milyen
szinteket lehet bejárni tehát én most
azt mondanám hogy
ne is vegyünk egy mlen csillagost
vegyünk egy egy átlag éttermet ott ahol
mindig teltház van mindig sokan járnak
az azt jelenti hogy az egy jó hely kell
legyen nyilván hogy ez
csapatmunkából áll össze az egész tehát
rengeteg ember dolgozik akinek
pozíciójai vannak tehát ebből kifolyólag
én csak annyit tudok mondani hogy ha
nézzük ezt a hierarchiát a legfelső
lépcsőszinten ugye ott van a séf a
legalsó szinten pedig ott van a mosogató
fiú vagy éppenséggel konyai kisegítő
bárminek nevezzük vannak a
középcsatárok mint a szakácsok
segédszakácsok cukrászoktól elkezdve
azok ezek mind azon dolgoznak hogy az a
hely mindig megleyen töltve és
el tudom azt is mondani például hogy a
legutolsó láncszem az a mosogató legény
vagy éppenséggel mosogatónő ha
hiányzik az akkor majdnem egy egész
rendszert tud bukni tőle tehát egy
kisegítőnek és egy mosogatónak is a
munkája legaláb láb olyan fontos mint a
séfé vagy a konyai vagy a a szakácsoké
tehát ez egy láncfolyamat én nem tudok
gyönyörű szép ételeket
felszolgálni hogyha a koszosakat ányírok
röviden összefogva ugye és az egyik fent
s a másik lent hasonló az emberi testhez
hogy azért mégis vannak különböző
szervek és különböző komplexitású
szervek de hogyha most együk fel a
májunk hiányzik akkor mit tudunk
csinálni vagy y tehát egy egy komplex
rendszerbe beleillik mégis menjünk végig
ezeken a szinteken hogy hova lehet
fejlődni mosogatás után mi a következő
szint mosogatás után szerintem nyugodtan
mehet egy konyai kisegítői poszt ami már
beenged esetleg a
desesszertek világába azt hogy te csak
kirakhatod esetleg még nem biztos hogy
megte kel te fogod megkészíteni de már
kirakhatod kirakhatsz egy salátát
elkészíthetsz egy savanyúságot
tételezzük fel szakácsnak lenni már
odaszó szokat kell tudni főzni már
foglalkozhatsz a köretekkel már kell
legyen egy ízlésvilágod már kell legyen
egy szervezőképességed amivel
megtervezed azt hogy a séf hogyha
készíti a finom húsait akkor te ahhoz
megfelelő köretet tudjál szépen felrakni
egy gyönyörű tállalásban annak meg kell
tervezni azt is hogy ugye hogyan teszed
fel és nyilván ezek mind mind mind mint
csapatmunkák amit gyakorlatilag a séf
irányít el ühüm tehát
ö utána a szakácsok után ugye a ez a ez
a szakma rengeteg ágazatán keresztül
megy tehát úgy a péktermékek úgy a a
sütemények desszertek tehát millió ágaz
ágazata van ennek az egésznek és
gyakorlatilag hogyha itthonról beszélünk
akkor ugye van egy egy séf a séfnek van
kettő szakácsa például
kettő segédszakácsa kettő kisegítője
váltásonként van két váltásod és
mindegyikben megvan hogy te hány embered
van és hány embert pozícionálsz be és
mire pozicionálod őket és akkor nyilván
hogyha te beosztod azt hogy ők neki ez a
pozíciója és ő ezeket a munkákon kell
keresztülmenjen a segédszakácsodnak és a
szakácsodnak megvan a pozíciója hogy ő
milyen munkákat kell elvégezzen akkor
egyértel az egész hogy te össze tudod
rakni hogy te mire vagy képes és milyen
ételeket tudsz lerakni a vendég elé
merzálmodozni nagyot mindig kell álmodni
nagyot mindig kell álmodni nagyot mi a
különbség a mesterzakács és a
szakácsmester
között a mesterszakács az egy az az
pozícióra sokkal nagyobb és nagyobb
felelőssége van mint a
szakácsmesternek szakácsmester kitalál
álhat új dolgokat de viszont a
mesterszakács nélkül nem tudja
megvalósítani a mesterszakács pedig nem
tudja megvalósítani éppenséggel az adott
vezetője nélkül tehát hogyha a
hierarerhiáról beszélünk és akkor a
mesterszakács és a sév között persze te
hát két lépcsőfok van tulajdonképpen
ühüm szakácsmester mesterszakács és
akkor m és akkor jön a séf íg rendben
szóval visszatekerhetünk arra a pontra
amikor az ifjú domi bement először és
mosogató leggényként konyhai
kisegítőként kezdett el dolgozni és
akkor mi történt utána veled
utánam egy spontán reggelről beszélünk
amikor amikor még a szakács nem volt
beérkezve a
munkahelyre bizonyos okokból kifolyólag
és megérkezett egy vendég aki egy egy
finom stakeet
kért és én mint tudatlan ember de
viszont első
ember volt az aki már a konyhán
megjelent mert nekem rengeteg
előkészületi munkám volt elmondta a
felszolgáló hogy itt van egy vendég
szakácsunk nincsen és domi ezt most te
kell megold ezt a sté sütést az egyik
legnehezebb tehát azt mondtad hogy a séf
az aki a húsokkal foglalkozik íg van így
van én elsőre nem akartam sőt nem is
mertem volna ezt megcsinálni de a
helyzet úgy adta hogy ezt ezt meg
kellett oldani valahogy a fejszolgálat
okért nem tanácsot hogy hogy kell
csináljam hogyan kell átpirítsam mennyit
kell pihentessem a tálalás az pedig
teljesen az enyém volt akkor
elkészítettem egy nagyon-nagyon finom
fogást ami gyakorlatilag jól sikeredett
és azketett a kezed gondolom igen igen
remegtem nagyon nem voltam biztos a
dolgombaan azt se tudtam hogy egyáltalán
jól csinálom vagy nem csinálom jól ez a
nyilván a pályafutásom kezdetén az a
vendég akinek kiadtam ezt a fogást annak
vendéglátó egysége volt
németországban és tette egy ajánlatot
hogy ő konyhai nem szakácsot keres hanem
konyhai kisegítőt keres nyilván az hogy
az étel nagyon finom volt én azt is
mondtam hogy én én akkor tehát a
szakáccsitulust messze-messze nem mertem
felvenni tehát na de viszont hogyha már
felajánlották a konyai kisegítői
pozíciót kint németországban 19 évesen
gondolkodás nélkül elfogadtam az egészet
és ez volt nekem egy ugródeszka a
szakmám fele hogy kint németországban
két évet dolgoztam és olyan
alapanyagokkal dolgozhattam és olyan
rendszerbe ami itthon még még még
nyomávan se volt a kialakulásának sem
hogy akkor már új ételeket kellett
kreálni minden egy hétvégére
olyan alapanyagokkal dolgoztam amit
életemben nem ismertem tehát egy egy
gyakorlatilag az alapanyagot fel kellett
kutassam hogy mi mi az és és akkor annak
idején nem volt
internet tehát
könvekből í van tehát könyvekből kellett
felkutatni érdeklődni szakácstól
kérdezni hogyan hogyan kell ezt az
alapanyaggal dolgozni hogyan kell
megművelni hogyan kell azt a kést fogni
én én elmondhatom tényleg hogy úgy
kezdtem a szakmát hogy hogy még még egy
kést se tudtam normálisan megfogni tehát
borotva éleskéssel 10 nap alatt min a 10
ujjamat össze-vissza vágtam tehát olyan
nehéz volt a annak idején a kezdet de
most pedig nyilván amikor amikor az
egyik segédszakácsom megkérdezi hogy
tudsz ilyen gyorsan vágni hát most
mondhatnám azt is hogy a rutin és a
tapasztalat de de meg akartam tanulni
tehát addig gyakoroltam azt a mozzanatot
és azt a fogást hogy a kést hogy kell
megfogni a a darabot stabilan kell
megfőz megfogni a deszkád nem mozoghat
ezek mind ilyen kicsi apró részek amit
hogyha esetleg valamelyiket kihagyod a
deszkád nem stabil és elcsúszik a darab
vagy a deszkád az újjat bánja a
legjobban tehát ezek ezek olyan fontos
dolgok hogy kicsi apróságokon múlik az
egész de ahhoz hogy hogy jól eltudd az
azt a azt a munkát végezni ahhoz ezek
fontosak igen gyakorlás gyakorlás
gyakorlás igen azóta amúgy lehet tanulni
ezt ittú
székelyudvarhelyen mármint hát van-e
szakácsiskola van-e valahol ahol ahol
vendéglátás és turizmus tehát a kos
károlybaan indítottak egy ilyet de azon
kívül én azt mondom hogy kiemelném a a
tast of transilvaniának a tankonyháját
ahol tényleg lehet tanulni már az
alapokat is akár ha valaki a
gasztronómiáb érdekelt akkor egyértelmű
hogy vagy érdeklődésst nyújt akkor
egyértelmű egy-egy tanfolyamot
továbbképzőt érdemes végigcsinálni a
boró infoná detto ott a ott a cukrászat
a pék
a pék továbbképzés a
zöldséggyümölcszobrászat az is működik
ott tehát vannak folyamatos
továbbképzések és hogyha valaki akar
érni egy szintet és ezt ezt meg akarja
tanulni érdemes ezeken a továbbképzőkön
részt venni mert megéri tényleg tehát
megtanulhatsz rengeteg
dolgot szakmának kisebb apróbb csinnyát
binnyát amit a
jövőre jövőben
felhasználhatsz csak tanuld meg tudjad
hogy azt úgy kell legyél elhivatott
akarja tehát személy szerint az az ember
aki aki jó szakember akar lenni
oda a hatalmas elhivatottság alázat
szeretet és tisztelet kell afele amivel
ő akar dolgozni tehát el lehet
sajátítani de viszont ezek mind ilyen
magánjellegű de én hát a vendéglátás és
turizmus szak itt nálunk
udvarhelyen elégg elenyésző tehát nem
nagyon lehet itt igazán megtanulni
nagyvárosokban már komolyabb iskolák
vannak külföldön már magániskolák vannak
és olyan diákokat gyűjtenek be akik akik
tényleg ezt akarják csinálni
magániskolába szóal németország mélyvíz
és két év mondjam úgy kénkeservesen telt
el nem tudom hogy hogy a vége már már
kez kezdett otthonosabban menni hogy
volt hogy a miért két évig maradtam m
nem négy évig például mi történt két év
után
igazából én honvágyas vagyok én itthon
érzem a legjobban magamat soha nem fogom
érezni egy országban tehát el nem tudnám
képzelni magam
például akármelyik nagy
európai ország
valamelyik fővárosába nem tudnám
elképzelni magam hosszútávon ott maradni
én annyira ragaszkodom a hazához a
környezetemhez a városomhoz és akkor
nyilván a teltmúlt az idő gyermekeim a
család
ühüm ők ők egyértelmű hogy idekötnek és
itt is tartanak tehát nekem nekem ők a
legfontosabbak és azt mondtam hogy az
amit külföldön el lehet érni
nagyvárosokbaan azt itthon is kemény
munkával biztos vagyok benne hogy hogy
el lehet érni csak rajtad múlik na hát
nézzük meg mi történt utána mert a
kemény munka az úgyó értettem és úgy
láttam hogy megvolt hazaköltöztél és ezt
azért merem így fogalmazni mert te írt
ezt magadról hogy nagy mellinnyel jöttél
haza hogy hogy milyen tudásod van és
akkor mi fogadott itthon igen érdekes
volt ez a ez az egész dolog mert tényleg
németországban
volt esélyem hogy elsajátítsam a zöldség
gyümölcszobrászat artisztikának a az
alap az alapjait mikor hazajöttem azt
hittem hogy
hú te már tudsz valamit én már tudok
valamit aztán birtalan boró
egyszerre az egyik étteremben dolgoztam
és birtalan boróka látogatott meg az
étterembe és látván az ételeimet mindig
ilyen faragott virágokkal és
zöldségekkel díszítettem gyönyörű szép
alkotásaim voltak tényleg a tálalásában
nagyon szép volt akkor annak idején ami
volt a trend az messze megállta a helyét
és akkor mondta boróka hogy menjek el
vásárhelyre a gasztropán kiállításra ez
pékcukrász
kiállítás délkelet-európa
egyik legnagyobb kiállítása menjek el
próbáld méretesen meg ott magam
próbálkozzak egyet mert ott is vannak
zöldséggyümölcszobrászok nézzem meg hogy
hadlám tetszik-e érdekel-e és amikor
eljutottam a gasztropánra akkor jöttem
rá
hogy még nagyon nagyon nagy nagyon
nagyon kezdetleges ez nekem számomra ez
a zöldség gyümölcszobrászat olyan
munkákat
láttam hogy gyakorlatilag felfoghatatlan
volt számomra hogy ilyeneket
lehet készíteni
kreálni és akkor jött a következő lépcső
hogy azt mondtam hogy na én ezt ez nekem
annyira tetszik hogy ezt meg akarom
tanulni és
időt energiát és pénzt fektettem ebbe
hogy amikor megláttam akkor még egyszer
kihangsúlyozom hogy nem volt internetes
világ
akkor megláttam a gizi csárdában varga
károly séf úrnak
a kreatív konyhaművészet
könyvét és amikor belelapoztam és láttam
hogy a virágok lépésről lépésre le
vannak fotózva hogy hogyan készüln nek
hogyan kell milyen mozdulakokat kell
alkalmazzál nekem ez nagyon megtetszett
na de ehhez felszerelés
kell kellett kutatni azt hogy hol kapok
én ilyen felszerelést a könyvben azt is
láttam hogy
árulják ezt a faragótskát amivel ezeket
a gyönyörű szép költeményeket el lehet
készíteni
és
amikor sikerült megvegyem az első
faragószettemet akkor rengeteg időt
áldoztam abba bele hogy tanulgassak hogy
gyakoroljak hogy szép virág szép
faragásaim legyenek szép virágaim
legyenek és hova tovább hogy elkezdtem
díszíteni az ételeket vele próbáltam
zöldséggyümölcs artisztika szempontjából
még egy szintet fennebb lépni próbáljuk
meg a dinnyefaragást próbáljuk meg a
tökfaragást tanulmányozzuk az
alapanyagokat juk össze hogy hogyan tud
ebből egy szép akár dekor dekoráció
lenni egy szép virágcsokor lenni egy
barátom megkért hogy az esküvőjére
készítsek egy szép gyümölcsasztalt azt
mondtam neki soha nem készítettem még
ilyet azt mondta olyan dinyét már
faragtál virágokat
faragtál farag nekem egy-egy dinnyét
kicsi virágokat tedd körbe
gyümölcsökkel és má meglátod hogy jó
vagány
lesz amikor megcsináltam az elsőt
annyira jól sikerült nekem nagyon
tetszett akkor még az a világ volt hogy
a fényképezőgépet rá kellett egy kábelen
kösd a
számítógépre fel kellett installáld az
egészet és akkor utána felraktad a
közösségi médiába akkor még nem volt
facebook csak ví meg meg ilyen ilyen h5
igen és odaatöltöttem fel a munkáimat és
és
meglepődtem hogy jött a következő
megrendelés hogy nekem kellene egy
ugyanolyan vagy hasonlóylyan vagy ez ez
most már a második alkalom amikor amikor
valami olyan dologba vágsz bele ami
meghaladja a képességeidet és azt mondod
hogy inkább vállalod azt a kockázatot
ami vele jár de nézzük meg mi történik
és nyertél de gyakorlatilag egy
absztrakt sárkány amit legyőztél í tehát
úgy alakul úgy úgy raktam össze a
gyümölcsasztaljaimat hogy kölcsön
kértem pető s nénitől a az állványt egy
másik cégtől másik vendéglátóegységtől
kölcsön kértem egy tükröt amire rá
tudjam szépen rakni a gyümölcsöket tehát
ilyen kölcsön dolgokból csak most
hétvégére idadják-e persze hogyne és
elkezdtük ezt az egészet így építgetni
és arra jöttem rá hogy hogy az a pénz
ami bejött ebből a gyümölcsasztalból én
próbáljam meg azt a azt az összeget
visszafektetni hogy saját felszerelé
vegyek és ne kelljen kérjem senkitől se
a felszerelést az plusz idő plusz
üzemanyag plusz költségek és nem is a
tiéd vigyáznod is kell úgy nyilván rá
azon gondolkoztam hogy vissza kellene
fektessem a pénzt hogy legy vegyek én
saját magamnak saját
eszközöket és jött a következő
megrendelésem és már egy adott
pillanatban azt vettem észre hogy
mindjárt egy kis vállalko
kelős közepén állok mert nem volt egy
olyan szabad hétvégénm hogy ne legyen
egy felkérésem rá ühüm és minél többet
csináltam készítettem annál szebb lett
annál gyönyörűbb lett fotóztam őket
nyilván laikus emberek amikor egy
rendezvényt megcsináltam egy ilyen szép
gyümölcsasztallal hát ők is hogy hogy
létezik ilyen s hogy van ilyen és itt
udvarhelyen és itt a környéken tehát
gyakorlatilag ennek a zöld
gyümölcszobrászatnak itt udvarhely
széken az egyik úttörőjének tudom
magamat mondani aztán váltak ki belőlem
még komoly szakemberek most
is van egy nagyon ügyes zöldség
gyümölcsfaragó szöcs klára
nevében gyönyörűeket alkot olyan
szépeket és látszik rajt benne is az
elszántság az elhivatottság hogy akarja
csinálni mindegyik munkája gyönyörű és
szép
öröm jó baráti kapcsolatot ápolun akkor
nincs versengés közzet nincsen versengés
sőt mit több én már azt mondtam hogy
minél jobban kezdtem inkább úgy a a
gasztronómia fele húzódni az artisztikát
egy kicsit úgy a háttérbe szorítottam
ebből kifolyólag mivel hogy a
gasztronómiára tettem több hangsúlyt
több időt és energiát az artisztika a
háttérbe szorult engem hívtak a
megrendelésekért a gyümölcsasztal
megrendelésekért és nyugodt szí el
örömmel tudtam átadni szöcs klárinak a
megrendeléseimet és azt mondtam neki
hogy vadok egy telefonszámot fel fognak
hívni téged egyezkedjetek beszéljetek
nekem kevésbé van időm most az
artisztikával foglalkozni és akkor úgy
szépen adtam át a munkákat és én mentem
a gasztronómia fele
folyamatosan folytassuk tovább az utadat
a hogyan vált belőled séf történetetz
mikortól tartod magad úgy hogy séf
lettél vagy ez egy ilyen hivatalos
kinevezés amikor amikor hogy lesz
valakiből séf én inkább azt mondanám
hogy itt nálunk fele azért eléggé
elcsépelt ez elcsépeltek ezek a
titulusok tehát most hogyha a séf az
gyakorlatilag főnököt jelent ugye vegyük
tételezzük fel
de viszont én inkább én azt mondanám nem
szeretem a titulusokat használni hogy
séf vagy mesterszakács vagy társai tehát
én megv én maradok egy szakemberként úgy
mint inkább szeretem azt a szót
használni hogy szakács üüm és
tehát mégis csak összefogod az embereket
tehát hogy hogy kell egy végső autoritás
aki m séként én most most gyakorlatilag
úgy dolgozok séfként hogy két csapatot
tartok össze gyakorlatilag az egységnek
a kreatív
szakácsa vagyok aki kitalálja megálmodja
a
fogásokat leszervezi a rendezvényeket
benevez esetleg
fotópályázatokba
gasztrofotópályázatokba folyamatosan
irányul hogy a gasztronómiában mit lehet
tartja az új trendeket meg társai de
viszont én úgy gondolom személy szerint
hogy azt a titulust hogy valaki azt
használja hogy ő séf valamilyen formában
ennek ezt ezt el kell iskolába kell
járni tehát egyetemre
vendéglátós iskolába ott ahol
megtanítják neked hogy hogyan kell te
pontosan gramra pontosan számolni mik
mit jelentenek a gazdasági mutatóknak a
figyelése az alapanyagoknak a mozgását
tehát ugye a gazdasági részét egy sév
folyamatosan kell figyelje hogy olyan
ételeket alkosson meg hogy azt ki tudja
ő számolni mennyibe kerül pontosan
mennybe kerül hány belőle csinálni
hányat tud belőle csinálni
ennek mekkora a ugye az anyagi vonzata
miből áll
össze gyakorlatilag egy fullcostot
folyamatosan ki kell számolni és ebből
azt is ki kell hogy számolja hogy mennyi
nyereséged van tehát az hogy a céged te
ne mínuszba vig hanem a pozitív
irányba nyilván amikor ugye telt házunk
van akkor nem dolgozhatunk úgy hogy nem
dolgozunk gazdaságosan teát érdekes hogy
egyszerre hány dimenziója van van egy
gazdasági dimenzió egy esztétikai
dimenziója nyilván egy
nutricionista oldalról kell megvizgálni
egy tehát most és és és emberekkel
dolgozol ráadásul tehát tételezzük fel
egy verseny vagy egy vagy egy ételnek a
megálmadásánál ha versenyről beszélünk
ezt ezt millió részre le lehet
bontani benevezünk egy versenyre például
annak már alapból van egy tematikája és
van egy versenykiírás amiben pontokra
van osztva hogy esetleg az az étel
milyen súlyban kell
megfeleljen az hogyha több vagy kevesebb
akkor mínuszpontokkal jár az az étel mit
kell képviseljen például hát én ha én
benevezek a magyarország étele versenyre
akkor a kiíráson belül én valahol kell
azt is vigyem hogy én milyen tájról
jöttem tehát székelyföldről jöttem akkor
bele kell csempészem az ételembe az
itteni hagyományokat esetleg az itteni
fűszereket gombákat alapanyagokat
egyértelmű tervezés az egész hogyan
tudsz te eljutni például a-ból b-be ha
te itthon eltervezed hogyan jutsz ki te
magyarországra mit kell gyél milyen
szponzorokra van szükséged milyen
alapanyagokra van szükséged hogyan
vitelezed ki az hogy te megáldotta a
helyedet kicsi apró dolgokon bukhat el
az egész tehát nagyon-nagyon oda kell
figyelni mikor megtervezünk egy például
egy egy versenyre kijutást szóval kicsit
előre mentünk de bele fogunk menni a
versenybe nagyon érdekel hogy te amiután
hazajöttél németországból utána mennyi
idő telt el és hogyan jutottál el oda
hogy hogy séfnek nevezhess
magad 13 év 14 tehát 14 év munka volt
ebben 14 év addig ameddig megléptem
azokat a lépcsőfokokat amire én azt
mondhatom hogy na most egy étteremnek a
séfjeként pozicionálhatom be magam és mi
történt ebbe a 14 évbe tehát hogy
folyamatosan részt vettél dolgoztál
tanultál beiratkoztál- egy iskolába akár
folyamatos továbbképzéseken vettem részt
és amikor én azt úgy éreztem hogy
elértem esetlegesen egy szakmai szintet
akkor ahhoz hogy ott megállom a
megállom-e a helyemet igyekeztem
benevezni egy versenyre ha az a verseny
sikeres volt akkor azt jelenti hogy na
én én azt a azt a szintet megléptem
úgyhogy kitűztem magam elé egy újabb
célt
hüüm amiután azt a célt is elkezdtem
megvalósítani megálmodni akkor megint
csak megversenyeztettem magam hogy
érezzem azt hogy lássam hogy hogy
körülbelül hol tartok tehát ez egy egy
egy saját verseny saját magammal azt
kell mondjam tulajdonképp és és a
sikerek azt bizonyították hogy igen én
ezt a szintet most már megléptem h jöhet
egy következő tehát mindig cél tehát
gyakorlatilag ezt a ezt a tizen évet úgy
tudom én
összefoglalni hogy folyamatosan tanultam
folyamatosan képeztem folyamatosan
utánajártam figyelgettem hogy mik az új
trendek és igyekeztem
azt azokat a trendeket meglépni
tanulmányozni az ételeimbe belevinni és
amiután úgy éreztem hogy hogy na ez
megvan akkor utána jött egy
megversenyeztetés az egészben hogy
tényleg megvan-e és amikor azt láttam
hogy hogy igen ezt a szintet elértem
akkor jött a következő tehát itt van két
külön doménium ami számomra különálló de
egymáshoz mégis szorosan kapcsolódó
doménium az egyik a
hétköznapi séfként élt életed és a másik
pedig a
verseny szféra azt hiszem hogy teljesen
más a kettő vagy pedig nem abszolút más
abszolút más kicsit járjuk körbe magát
azt akkor hogy milyen egy hétköznapja
egy séfnek és hogy mit jelent az hogy
nem versenyre készülsz hanem újra és
újra és újra ugyanazokat az ételeket
kell
előállítsátok hogy mi történik egy
konyhában és nagyon érdekelnek ott a
belső hogy honnan szerztek be az
alapanyagokat és mikor ezt jól
körbejártuk akkor egy kicsit menjünk át
a verseny szférába hogy lássuk hogy ott
mi történik mitől verseny a verseny és
hogyan lehet ezt díjazni szóval
ilyesmiket fogok majd kérdezni de most
egyelőre a hétköznapi rész érdekel 14 év
alatt felküzdötted magad ahhoz hogy egy
egy éttermet nagyon minőségi módon
összefogj a háttérbe az embereket
összefog rengeteg dimenziója van ennek
kezdjük például azzal hogy
egy séf az aki kitalálja ugye a menüt
aki kitalálja az új koncepciókat a hogy
hogy mi mennyibe kerüljön és hogy
gazdasági vatokat hy van egy gazdasági
vonatkozása és nyilván ez ez magával van
minden tehát gyakorlatilag esztétikailag
hogy néz ki az ízvilága milyen és ez
hogyan történik például amikor a a
kükülő étteremhez csatlakoztál mi volt
az első lépésed azt felkértek hogy itt
van van két hónapod most nem tudom
mennyi idő de ezt talán meg is oszatod
vel mennyi idő alatt lehet újra tervezni
egy egy menüt mit csinálsz ilyenkor mit
csináltál
ilyenkor most
tételesen bármelyik étteremről beszélünk
ugye valahol valamilyen formában minden
szakásnak vagy mondjuk azt hogy séfnek
van egy kézjegye van egy stílusa amibe
őt állal mindig beleviszi ő a saját
stílusát abba az ételbe de viszont
egy étlap megtervezése rengeteg
idő minél te rengeteget kell
gondolkozzunk jól át kell járjuk hogy az
a stílust amit mi képviselni akarunk
azok az ízek azok az alapanyagok amit mi
képviselni
akarunk kell egy
egy kutatás egy felmérés hogy oké hogy
te ezt akarod de a vendégek ezt
akarják-e tehát
bemegyünk a konyhára megcsináljuk a
próbát megkóstoljuk de például ahhoz
hogy egy étlap összeálljon én mindig
vacsorákat
készítettem volt egy menüsor egy
négyfogásos menüsor készítettünk egy
finom előételt készítettünk egy finom
levest egy vacsorát egy
desszertet
és azt tanulmányoztuk hogy az a világ
amit mi képviselünk a vendégkörnek
rendben van-e tetszik-e ők ezt akarják-e
és
amikor pozitív
visszajelzéseket kaptunk úgy az étterem
mint a szakács is akkor azt mondtuk hogy
na ez a ez az étel ez a desszert ezek
ezek mehetnek az új étlapra és az
átlagember kompetens eléggé ahhoz hogy
meg tudja mondani hogyha valami nem
tetszik szerintem igen igen és de nekem
nincs alig vannak szavaim hogy egy étel
jó persze azt tudom mondani hogy túl el
van sülve vagy túl sós vagy ezek olyan
primitív dolgok de azokat a finom nanszi
dolgokat honnan tudod összeszedni tehát
tulajdonképpen az hogy valami túl van
sütve vagy vagy túl van fűszerezve nem
csak ebből áll össze az étel de viszont
ezekre nagyon oda kell figyelni a
technológiákra oda kell figyelni milyen
technológia alkalmazol azt a
technológiát betartod-e úgy ahogy a nagy
könyvbe le van írva például mert hogyha
ha betartod és úgy csinálod ahogy az
kell annak csak a vége mindig jó lehet
üüm tehát azt nem lehet nem nem
mondhatom azt hogy tényleg ha én ha ha
úgy van kitalálva az egész étel hogy
ennyit sütöd ennyit
konfitálod ennyit kell itt tarts ennyit
kell megpihentesd hogyha te azt leírod
és folyamat osan betartod akkor csak azt
veszed észre hogy minőségi ételeket adsz
ki tehát a technológiákat tanulni kell
és rengeteget gyakorolni és az ember a
hibájából nagyon sokszor észreveszi azt
hogy na hogyha ennél a pontnál
elrontottam akkor többet
ne mire kell figyelni egy étlap esetében
még az alapanyagok úgy legyenek
összeállítva az étlap úgy legyen
összeállítva hogy legyen választék
legyen színes legyen gazdag
én azt mondom hogy
szeretem az ételeimet
összeállítani körettel esetlegesen egy
savanyúsággal vagy szósszal egy finom
hús egy finom ropogós tálalásában meg
megálmodni azt hogy milyen tányérra
teszed rá ahhoz hogy az tényleg jól is
mutasson a színeket megválogatni hogy
passzol-e egyik a másikkal tehát ezek
ezekre folyam oda kell figyelni gondolom
az árkategória is fontos hogy legyenek
mindenféle kategóriában levő ételek így
van tehát többféle alapanyaggal
dolgozunk ugye van a felsőbb a drágábbik
alapanyagok vannak közép kategóriás
alapanyagok vannak az a az egyszerűen
elkészült
alapanyagok olyan tehát a vendégkörre
mindenkire is kell figyelni tehát nem
csak a felső rétegre hanem a középr
rétegre is ugyanúgy kell f figyelni mert
elvégre ők tartanak fent minket és mi
igyekszünk annyi és olyan r annyi embert
bevonzani hogy mindenki elégedetten
távozzon és mindenki megkapja a saját
magáihoz valót tehát az lehet szó egy
salátáról lehet szó egy halfféléről
tehát azt mondtam hogy az alapanyagokat
é az étlapot is úgy állítom hozzá hogy
ott legyen rajta marhahús legyen rajta
sertéshús csirke hal bárány tehát
többféle alapanyaggal salátákból is
olajakból is tehát hogy a az alapanyagok
is olyan alapanyagok legyenek amik
minőségi alapanyagról szólnak és mindig
finom ízeket adnak hogy
úgy kalkulálni az egészet hogy mindenki
megkapja a magáét ne csak a felső réteg
vagy ne csak a középr réteg és honnan
jönnek ezek az alapanyagok most például
a te esetedben most a kükülő étterem
esetében rengeteg sok beszállítóval
dolgozunk de viszont
én kutatok folyamatosan a helyi termelők
fele helyi
termelőkből pedig azt mondom hogy
például hogyha gombát akarok
gombaféléket akarok akkor az etelaki
közbirtokosságot hoz megyek mert tudom
hogy ők begyűjtik a gombát leszedik a
leszedetik a gombát begyűjtik a gombát
átmossák a gombát megtisztítják a gombát
sokkolják és
értékesítik olyan minőségbe amit
gyakorlatilag te ugy az ételembe az
erdőn szedett gombát nem viheted be mert
az nincsen levédve nem szabad bevinni
mert nem engedik meg a a szervek hogy te
erdőből szedett gombát hanem neked is
ugye nyilván le kell legyen papírozva
azt hogy az a mert egy bármilyen
mérgezés bármi előfordulhat te le kell
magadat védjed hogy te olyan
alapanyaggal dolgozol ami ami biztos
főleg ugye ami a helyi termelőket illeti
ezek ezek nagyon fontos vagy vegyük a a
ugyancsak a helyi termelőket húsokat
milyen egy szürkeemarha milyen egy
mangalica vagy éppenséggel háziity
tyókkal dolgozol-e vagy éppenséggel a a
friss halat az tényleg halászatból
veszed pisztrángostól veszed a
pisztrángot vagy
éppenséggel fagyasztottat
értékesítesz óriási különbségek vannak
minden téren tehát hogyha min ségi
alapanyaggal dolgozol helyi termelőknek
a termékeivel dolgozol támogatod a helyi
termelőket és nyugodtan dolgozol te is
mert tudod hogy az a miénk helyi és
minőség most ebben a pillanatban ha most
kéne egy 10 pontot szétossz a helyi
termelők és a beszállítók között akkor
hány százaléka vagy hány pontot adnál a
helyi termelőknek
hogy hány hányból tudod
lefedni maximális maximális majdnem én
azt mondom hogy helyi termelőknek
legalább 788 százalékával örömmel
dolgozok ühüm örömmel és a az az
étlapodnak hány
százaléka hát egy olyan én igyekszem
most idáig egy olyan 60%-ánál vagyunk
úgy mint helyi termelőkel dolgozunk igen
az beszélünk itt a sajtokról beszélünk
néhány húsokról beszélünk salátáról
beszélünk
alapanyagbeszerzésben helyi termelőkkel
és olyan helyi termelők akik nyilván
le tudnak fedni minket számlával ki
tudnak szolgálni mindig tehát ez mi az
amit nem tudsz egyáltalán helyi
termelőkkel elintézni h nem is tudnám
ezt ezt most az hogy helyi termelőkkel
tehát helyi termelőknek a a helyi
termékeit keresem de most azt hogy mit
nem tudok velük megoldani majd majdnem
bármit meg lehet velük oldani tehát
hogyha például olajokat kell arra is van
példa akkor hogyne például hogyha
olajakat akarok akkor helyi termelőt
választok a gastr módot választom széci
attilát választom mert
kiváló tökmagolaja van kiváló
szezámolaja van mákolaja van tehát
egyértelmű vele is dolgozok jelenleg de
viszont már csak olajokból is van hely
termelő aki aki itt készíti
székelyudvarhelyen itt hidegen sajtója
és értékesíti tehát egyértelmű hogy van
már ebből is egy helyi termelünk ha a
pisztrángot
keresek akkor egyértelmű helytermelőnek
nevezzük azt is akinek pisztrángosa van
aki kifogja aki kibelezi és aki aki
pucolva készen elhozza hozzád és
vállalja a minőségét is az ő saját
alapanyagának tehát nagyon sok mindent
le lehet fedni vegyük csak a
fűszereinket fűszereink az ugye csombor
kapor tárkony leostyán friss
petrezsjemző millió tehát gazdagok
vagyunk mi nagyon-nagyon gazdagok
vagyunk
alapanyagokkal már az vegyük a az erdőt
málna erdeji eper gombafélék medvehagyma
tehát amit a természet ont ki magából
rókagombától kezdve gazdagok vagyunk
vegyük a vadhúsainkat
ugye tehát szarvas ős én nagyon élvezem
ezt a mosolygószemeket ahogy mesélsz az
ét tehát székelyföld ontja magából ühüm
a finomabbnál finomabb eredetibbnél
eredetibb és a minőségi alapanyagokat
tehát nem igaz hogy csak külföldön lehet
kapni vagy lehet szertenni minőségi
alapanyagraőt sőt a miénk az a miénk és
nekünk még az a dolgunk hogy a mi helyi
alapanyagainkat tegyünk bele egy kicsi
csavart formáljuk meg gondolkozzunk
építsünk fel egy olyan ételt ami
megállja esetleg a nemzetközi konyhán is
a helyét úgy hogy vigyázva őrizve
gyökereinket hogy miből indult el ez az
egész h egyértelmű ha tetszik ez az
epizód akkor kérlek ne felejtsetek el
feliratkozni a csatornánkra osszátok meg
valamint hagyjatok egy kommentet ezzel
nagyban segítitek a munkánkat e ez ez
nagyon érdekes ez egy szűk szelete ahhoz
képest tehát hogy gyakorlatilag amiről
most beszéltünk az hogy egy étlap ahhoz
hogy összeálljon kell figyelj
gyakorlatilag egyértelműen az igényekre
tehát kifele kell figyelj nem nem az
egódat belevinni azt és hogy hogy te mit
szeretnél hanem folyamatosan figyelni a
visszajelzésekre majd később kiszámolni
hogy hogyan tud ez gazdaságos lenni
honnan lehet ezeket beszerezni mennyi
gondolom a a a szavatossági idejük és
hogy hogyan figyelni erre pontos e e ez
e gyakorlatilag egy komplex logisztika a
háttérbe totálisan és akkor még nem
beszélt ja igen és gyanítom hogy utána
elmondod a tulajdonosnak hogy ah hogy
ezeket el tudjam készíteni egy ilyen
konyhára van szükségem ilyen eszközökre
van szükségem egy ekkora helyre
gyakorlatilag ez ez és ez az egyik
szeletem most eg kicsit áttérnék a
szervezetfejlesztésnek annak a a azon
oldalára amikor emberekkel
foglalkozunk két csapatot tartasz össze
összesen ez hány személy 12 12 személy
így van gyakorlatilag emberekhez is kell
tudj érteni és az egyik dolog amit
egyből észrevettem rajtad az hogy egy
extrovertál személy vagy aki amúgy amúgy
egy ritkaság tehát hogy inkább
introvertáltak vagyunk a itt
székelyföldön látszik hogy pezsegsz
emberek között hogy örülsz annak hogyha
feltölt hogyha emberek között vagy
milyen kihívásai
vannak amivel találkozol így a ebben a a
világban azt hogy emberekkel foglalkozol
igen van nekem sokszor
elszoktam van egy ilyen köpésem azt
szoktam mondani hogy két lábú akkor
rengeteg baj van
igen a legnehezebb dolog ser sokan
vagyunk sokfélék nem vagyunk egyformák
hála istennek na de
viszont mértéktelen tisztelet kell a
kollegád fele legyen mert én én alapból
úgy gondolkozok hogy egyedül semmire se
vagyok képes hogyha nincsenek olyan
szorgos kezek és olyan kollégák akik
segítenek ahhoz hogy a én a saját én az
álmaimat megvalósítsam ha én
megvalósítom az álmaimat nyilván ért a a
vezetőmnek az álmait is valósítom de ez
viszont olyan kemény csapatmunka tehát
személy szerint én nagyon-nagyon
tisztelettel vagyok az összes kollégám
fele és figyelem hogy kinek éppenséggel
mert ugye minden napunk más van amelyik
kollégának éppenséggel pocsékedve van
vagy társai figyelem azt is hogy neki
milyen a hangulata mert mert erre is oda
kell
figyelni ha éppen éppenséggel valami őt
zavarja vagy társai akkor négy szem közt
kihívod megkérdezed mi a probléma
tudsz-e segíteni mert látod hogy valahol
valamilyen formában el van havazva
tehát nagyon nagyon nagyon fontos
számomra az hogy mindegyik kollégám
amikor bent van a konyhán akkor fejbe is
ott legyen és tudjak számítani rá
amelyikre úgy látom azt hogy
éppenséggel zavart állapotban van vagy
társa igyeksz megkérdezni hogy minden
rendben vagy talán mivel miben tudok
segíteni nyilván hogy a a munkát is úgy
osztom rá arra az emberre hogy ő azt
érezze hogy foglalkozok vele ha látom
hogy el van akadva segítek neki mindig
azt kérdeztem ha valamiet nem tudnak nem
értenek bármikor kérdezzenek nyugodtan
válaszolok ha tíszer kérdezzik meg
tíszer
válaszolok ha nem ha nem vagyok az
egységben akkor telefon éjjel nappal
elérhető vagyok hogyha bármilyen
tanácsokra van szükségük vagy valahol el
vannak akadva mindig elérhető vagyok én
számukra tát gyakorlatilag érezned kell
a csapatot pontosan tehát szabadnapomon
is gyakorlatilag a szakmán és a
munkahelyemen töröm a fejemet hogy
tudjam még könnyebben még jobban
csinálni még egyszerűbben még
gyorsabban az
egész napom egy tervezés mindig
megtervezem reggel úgy kelek fel hogy
kell nekem legyen egy 40 perces énidőm
ahol nyugodtan megkávézok és elgondolom
eltervezem a napomat amit már este úgy
fekszem le hogy nagyjából tudom hogy
mivel fogom kezdeni azt reggel
összesíttem és így indulok neki dolgozni
minden majdnem percre pontosan meg van
tervezve hogy ne csússzak ki és még így
is van amikor megcsúszok hm azt hiszem
hogy most kellően körbejártuk egyelőre
magát hát a nem még egy kérdésem van
pontosabban az a személy akinek érezlek
hogy hogy egy pezsgő kreatív
egyfolytában új dolgokon agyalsz ez ez
hogyan fér össze azzal hogy újra és újra
és újra ugyanazokat az ételeket kell
elkészíteni nem mondanám azt hogy újra
elkészíteni mert van nekünk ugye egy
standard étlap amit gyakorlatilag
megtanulunk amit bármikor kell
készítsünk na de viszont
és azokat örömmel tudod csinálni azokat
az ételeket amiket már 20szor 30-szor
50szer 500-szor csináltál mindig vannak
mindig mindig mindegyik étel más
mindegyik étel éppenséggel van egy
egyénisége hogy ne legyen
monoton tehát de ugye megvan a standard
étlapunk azt mi megtanultuk és tudjuk
hogy ez mindig így nagyjából így kell
kinézzen tehát ahogy beérkezik a
rendelés fejbe neked van egy fotó a
fejedbe hogy tudod hogy ezt az ételt ezt
így kell így áll össze így kommunikálod
le kollégáiddal hogy ez mindig olyan
kell legyen de viszont ez annál többet
jelent
tehát van a termelőegység akik készítik
az ételeket és van vagyok én aki aki
kigondolja hogy azon az étlapon kívül
még vannak ugye rendezvények keresztelők
esküvők versenyek minden és azoknak az
ételeit is ki kell találni át kell
gondolni nekem ehhez nagyon fontos a
csend otthon szoktam lenni csendben
gondolkozok nem kell sok idő fél óra az
a fél óra alatt ameddig összerakom azt a
koncepciót utána már elkezdek zenét
hallgatni és inspirálódom együtt a
zenével és találom ki álmodom meg írom
le csinálom meg a receptúráját azoknak a
fogásoknak tehát nem egy monoton
szakmáról beszélünk az amit amit én
csinál
soha nem is volt monoton nincsen két
egyforma nap soha h ez nagyon érdekes
hogy az ételnek azt mondod hogy van egy
identitása erről egy kicsit tudnál
beszélni bővebben hogy mit értesz
identitás alatt mert a laikus ember
számára az egy flekken kirakva
krumplival és tegyük fel valami színes
dolog mellé de hogy mi mi az identitása
van egy ételnek hát úgy fogalmaznám meg
azt hogy van egy identitása hogy
ha
éppenséggel be akarok nevezni vagy egy
egy ételt el akarok készíteni például
próbába akkor igyekszem megcélozni egy
egy
vendégkört ahhoz az ételt is
úgy készítem el hogy annak olyan
identitása legyen hogy egészséges
legyen gyönyörű szép tálalásban
technológiákat vigyünk bele és mégis
ragaszkodjunk a hagyományainkhoz tehát
identitásban én inkább azt mondanám hogy
arra figyelek oda hogy
úgy alkalmazzak technológiákat és úgy
készítsem el az ételt hogy a miénk
legyen de mégis a vendég totálisan a
magáinak érezze minden egyes
mozzanatát az egész ételnek minden egyes
falatát azért el itt még fejemben van
egy pár gondolat kíváncsi vagyok mi a
véleményed így ezzel az identitással
kapcsolatban egyrészt hozunk egy múltat
tehát gyermekként hogyan nőttünk fel
milyen ízvilágot tapasztaltunk meg a mi
a miénk és összeköt tehát gyakorlatilag
amikor egy ételt megkóstolok nem csak
mondjam úgy hogy nyers anyagot viszek be
a számba hanem egy emléket viszek be a
számba ez az egyik a másik pedig hogy az
étellel szoktunk ünnepelni tehát az
ünnepeink azok amelyek tehát amikor
ünnepelni akarunk mit csinálunk szépen
felöltözünk
szép zenét hallgatunk elmegyünk egy
olyan helyre amely dekoratívan van
feldíszítve és elkezdünk enni de nem úgy
eszünk hogy külön elizolálóva hanem
közösségben eszünk és ezek az elemek
gyakorlatilag olyan mint hogyha egy
szentmisén vennénk részt egy egy szinte
minthogyha egy ilyen spirituális
közeg születne meg ott az étteremben
azáltal hogy közösségben finomat
dekoratívat zenével együtt örömmel tehát
nem hiába alakultak így az ünnepeink
hogy mind közösen étkezünk és ha
gyakorlatilag te ebben veszel részt ezt
gyakorlatilag megálmodod és megpróbálod
olyan nyelvezettel kifejezni ezt az
ünnepet ami a te kezedben van tehát mint
séf az ételeknek a nyelvezetén fejezed
ki de ugyanígy pont annyira látom a
művészi oldalát mint egy zenének vagy
mint egy egy egy rendezvényszervezőnek
aki fel ki kidekorálja a helyet te ezt
így látod ennyire egyértelmű vagy n
romantizálom túl bontsuk szét ezt ezt a
ezt az ünnepet ezt az étkezési ünnepet
hát ünnepről beszélünk akkor is ugye
amikor karácsony van amikor húsvét van
és amikor egy közösségben otthon
egymásnak főzünk vagy éppenséggel
édesanyám elkészíti a kedvenc töltött
káposztánkat vagy a legfinomabb zsidó
tojást vagy töltött tojást
húsvétkor ünnepekre bontjuk le ezt hogy
otthon is é akkor is az egy ünnep és fel
vagyunk költözve szépen és a vasárnapi
mise után együtt a család
összharmóniában csodálatos szeretettel
megebédelünk ez is egy ünnep de vannak
ugye más ünnepek vannak születésnapok
vannak keresztelők
vannak esküvők ezek nagyobb volumenű
ünnepek itt már nagy
emberlétszámot mozgósítunk meg tehát ide
már bár tényleg amikor egy egy
étteremen le kell bonyolítsunk egy egy
ilyen ünnepet mint egy esküvő például
akkor egyértelmű hogy teljesen más annak
az identitása teljesen másképp kell te
szervezzél
és bele tudunk ebbe annyi mindent
csempészni hogy tényleg igazán ünnep
legyen és mi szakácsokul és mi
vendéglátósokul mi azért vagyunk hogy az
az embereknek örömet szerezzünk a vendég
szeretetünkkel a finom ételeinkkel a
gyönyörű
felszolgálásainkkal hányan vagyunk mi
toppon hányan vagyunk mi keményen talpon
és végezzük a munkánkat azért hogy az az
ember kényelmesen szeretettel ünnepelje
a saját rendezvényét ha még tegyük fel
még szavakkal nem is tudod kifejezni
mert ez talán az is lehet ki tudod
fejezni de érzel egy különbséget egy
céges rendezvény és egy keresztelő
között tehát mikor tervezed az ételt
akkor valahogy úgy érzed hogy ez nem
illik egy keresztelőbe és ez nem illik
egy céges rendezvénybe
nyilván el tudunk menni ezt is fel
tudjuk bontani egy céges esemény ugye
többnyire ott a cégvezetőtől függ hogy
mi a megrendelé mit szeretne ő milyen
vendégköre van neki és egy keresztelőnél
ugye aztán mindig ki kell tegyünk
magunkért tehát az az egyértelmű hogy
egy keresztelő az egy hatalmas ünnep
vagy egy első áldozás nagy ünnep egy
esküvő szintén nagy ünnep egy céges
rendezvény az tulajdonképp miről szól
egy köszönetről amikor a cégvezető
megköszöni az embereinek hogy kiartottak
mellette egy egész éven keresztül vagy
hány éven keresztül ezt tulajdonképp
ugye össze lehet kötni azt hogy az a
vezető köszönetet mond az embereinek és
mi megteszünk mindent hogy azok az
emberek azok a szorgalmas emberek akik
dolgoztak egy egész éven keresztül na ők
is olyan jól érezzék magukat úgy az
ételekkel mint a felszolgálással hogy
érezzék hogy egész évben keményen
dolgoztak és most ők vannak
kiszolgálva tehát ezek ezek ilyen kicsi
apró dolgok különbséget komolyabban nem
tennék mert
úgy egy céges eseménynél mint egy
keresztelőnél a maximumot kell mindig
kihozzuk magunkból és a maximumot
kellett együk az asztalra mindig azt
hiszem hogy ezt a részét körbenár
körbejártuk kellően nagyon érdekelne a
verseny hogy miért fontos számodra a
verseny ez az első és láttam hogy számos
versenyen vettél részt és akkor
kicsit például nézzük meg a legutolsó a
legnagyobb volumenű versenyedet amin
részt vettél vezess be minket hogy
honnan
indult hogyan zajlott le mi mi lett a
végeredménye és miért volt fontos
számodra azt hiszem hogy ezen a példán
kereszt jól körbejárjuk az összes többi
más vá versenyt
igen ez ha jól tudom a hosszú és kemény
útról beszélünk tehát az hogy valaki
kijusson az olimpiára ide
ide nagyon-nagyon sokat kell dolgozni és
kell tenni iss azért hogy te ott
lehessél nagyon rég régi álmom volt az
hogy egy ilyen nagyobb volóenűvel
versenyen részt vehessek és úgy gondolom
hogy az elmúlt 19 évben annyi mindent
tettem hogy örültem hogy varga károly
séf úr
felkért és számított rá arra hogy
esetleg a esetlegesen a csapatot
erősítsem az olimpia az több kategóriára
volt osztva ott voltak cukrászok volt
hideg étel meleg étel levesek
mi az
artisztikába képviseltettük magunkat az
enyém a sóstészta volt és a
zöldséggyümölcs artisztika
ugye nyilván a csapatnak a ezt a az
artisztikába az
egyik tagja én vagyok
és már előtte nekem volt egy olyan
múltam hogy azt mondtam a öldség
gyümölcs artisztikában már van
tapasztalatom és
varga károly séfúr úgy gondolta hogy ő
engem szeretne beválogatni abba a
csapatba amit ő irányít azért hogy
megmérettessük magunkat és szintet
tudjunk lépni ahhoz hogy még jobbak
legyünk és hagyjunk valami maradandót is
saját magunk után a következő
generációnak is akár hogy tudjunk
példakép lenni esetleg fiataloknak és
szakemberek nek mert ez nagyon fontos
mert
varga károly séfúr és
csapatától én azt tanultam hogy ami a
tiéd azt add tovább h az olyan embernek
akibe tanulás vágy van az olyan embernek
ad tovább aki érdeklődik efele ne tartsd
meg magadnak ami a tiéd add tovább ez
nagyon nagyon fontá ez a bőségmentalitás
tényleg áthatja így ahogy mondod meg jó
párszor így így a történeteiden
keresztül érződik ez a bőségmentalitás
igen szóval elindult a tehát 2024
februárjában volt így van ez a
nemzetközi olimpia szakácsolimpia itgá
így van stuttgartban itt akkor több
ország méretkezett meg egymással hány
ország vett részt hát egész
európa ázsia ugye tájföld kína japán
ez így a szakmádnak az egyik csúcsa a a
a vagy vagy hogy h természetesen igen
tehát ez akkora volumenű rendezvény
akkor a vonulmenő verseny hogy ez már ez
már jelent egy csúcsot de én azon az
alapelven vagyok hogy amikor az ember
tehát nincs olyan hogy valahol
abbahagyjuk hogy azt mondjuk hogy na
most itt vagyunk legfelül és már többet
nemüüm tehát mindig amikor az előbb is
ahogy meséltem hogy elérünk egy célt és
kitűzünk egy
következőt azt is amikor elértük akkor
úgy is kell legyen még egy következő
mert hanem úgy gondolom hogy monotonná
válik az embernek a munkája és hogyha
nem tűzöl ki célt akkor észreveszed azt
hogy egy kiégésen vagy az amit idáig
csináltál azt nézed hogy hirtelen kezd
elslamposodni tehát mindig mindig mindig
új új cél ok at mindig kell kitaláljál
nem szabad szerintem még hogyha elérsz
tényleg egy világbajnokságon egy
aranyérmet akkor akkor az legyen a
következőóog cél hogy azt azt meg
tudod-e újravalósítani hogy még egyszer
meglegyen nem kell abbah hagyni
szerintem mikor elértél egy maximum
csúcsot van vannak magasabbak is
pontosan ez a stagnálás ezzel igen ez
számomra fontos tanulság volt hogy az
ember amikor céltalanul éli a az életét
akkor nem az van hogy egy ilyen
neutrális állapotba éli hogy akkor se
nem jó se nem rossz hanem a céltalanság
az önmagában egy elviselhetetlen
szenvedés az ember életébe és tényleg
fontos hogy hogy célod legyen ezzel
tovább a felkészültél elmentél
stutgardba a cikkben
nagyon szemléletesen leírtad hogy
valójában mennyire egy fizikailag is
megterhelő időszak volt ez pontosan
meg hogy az előtte levő felkészülési
időszak is gyakorlatilag megterhelő volt
és ráadásul még szponzorokat kellett
gyűjteni mesélnél akkor erről az
időszakról mi mi miért olyan megterhelő
igen örültem ennek a hogy erre voltál
tulajdonképp kíváncsi igen a
felkészülési időszak az megterhelő mert
azon kívül hogy az most ha magamról
beszélek soha életemben ilyen nagy
volumenű versenyre még nem voltam
nyilván nekem is megvolt a hátterem a a
hátterem az az egyesületünk a nyolc
régió kulináris
egyesület ez volt a háttér amit varga
károly séf úr pár kollégámmal együtt
megalapítottak és amiben úgy gondolták
hogy én is részt kell
vegyek nyilván ekkora volumenű versenyen
ahol ennyire ennyire pontosan kell
dolgozni és mindent figyelnek
centimétereket
magasságokat összet ételt hát nagyon
nehéz volt számomra a felkészülés mert
soha nem volt tapasztalatom ilyen
volumenű versenyre most most
megtapasztaltam hogy miből áll össze ez
az egész és azt mondom hogy következőre
mikor készülünk újra máris okosabb
leszek és máris tudom hogy milyen
apróságokra kell odafigyeljek de maga a
fejkészülési része mennyi időt készültél
rá nag nagyon hát egyszer az hogy
állványt kellett terveztetni tehát
amikor kigondoltuk azt hogy mi lesz a
téma amivel indulunk azt meg kell
tervezni meg kell tervezni azt hogy
milyen alapanyagokkal dolgozol m mire
teszed fel milyen hátteret készítesz
neki milyen asztalra fogod feltelni
hogyan lesz az
megvilágítva ezek ezekre mind tehát
gyakorlatilag a versenyen kaptál egy
asztalt és azt az asztalt te töltötted
meg a te
munkáddal mindent kicsit aprólékosan meg
kellett tervezni az egészet nyilván
segítettek a séfurak is mert azt mondtam
hogy az ők segítségük nélkül és az ők
tapasztalataik
nélkül nem tudok neki állni ezt
megtervezni
úgyhogy rengeteg segítséget kaptam a
csapattársaimtól
úgy a
felkészülésbe míg az mint az ott lévő
ákba hogy egy csapatba dolgoztunk és a
csapat összeállt és mindenki segített
mindenkinek ahhoz hogy összejöjjön ez a
négy ezüstérem és két bronzérem csapaton
belül tehát így tértünk hazza a hatalmas
büszkeséggel aminek nagyonnagyon
örventünk de nyilván ahhoz hogy te
kijussál romániából stuttgardba ahhoz
nyilván nekem is szponzorokra volt
szükségem én milyenonz okat szoktam
magam köré gyűjteni hát például
megkeresek olyan vendéglátó egység
tulajdonosokat vagy éppen tehetősebb
vállalkozókat akiktől gyakorlatilag nem
anyagi forrást kérek hogy pénzt kapjak
hanem segítsenek az utamon az hogy
eljussak a-ból b-be példának ezt
mondanám üzemanyag üüm valahogy el kell
jutni külföldre és hogyha nekem
biztosítják az üzemanyagot a akkor az
már nekem egy hatalmas segítség ha
elmegyek egy céghez ahol alumíniummal és
vassal foglalkoznak és meg tudják nekem
tervezni az
állványomat az hatalmas segítség az is
már egy hogy a tervedet amit megalkottál
szépen lassan összeáll megvan az
állványod megkerestem egy nagyon jó
barátomat aki fába egy olyan ajzatot al
ított ki a lugalux régió barátom zolti
olyan ajzatot tervezett ahogy azt
tényleg a séf úr nekem kérte hogy ekkora
kell legyen centire pontosan mert azokat
is figyelik hogy milyen magas kell
legyen
milyen mekkora kell legyen ahhoz hogy
jól mutasson nekem a séf úr
gyakorlatilag ezt megtervezte én a
kivitelezésbe pedig meg kellett keressem
azokat az embereket akik nekem tudnak
segít teni hogy ezek
összeálljanak akkor nyilván meg kell
oldjuk a szállásunkat meg kell oldjuk az
étkeztetésünket meg kell oldjuk az
alapanyagainkat ha a
zöldséggyümölcszobrászattal indulok neki
például egy versenynek mert mert abba
helyezkedem el akkor én azon is kell
gondolkozzak hogy találjak egy olyan
helyi termelőt vagy éppenséggel zöldség
lerakatot aki se segít nekem abban hogy
az alapanyagokkal kiszolgál mert nagyon
nehéz beszerezni télen dinnyét vagy
éppenséggel a lehető legjobb minőségű
alapanyagok hogy a kezembe jussanak
akkor én én
tényleg beszélek most a c+ c-ről vagy
most már szezon végén úgy indultunk ki
szlovákiában egy gyönyörű szép
gálavacsorára hogy gyakorlatilag a
dinnyeszezon már elmúlt és meg kellett
keressek egy ügyes helyi termelőt
keresztúron kaptam is egyet bánlehel
nevében akinek olyan gyönyörű szép
dinnyéi voltak hogy azt mondta hogy
időbe szóltál mert most már szántom bele
az egészet a földbe olyan alapanyaggal
biztosította hogy azt mondtam hogy öröm
volt már eleve dolgozni is belőle tehát
látszott hogy az olyan alapanyagot
készítő olyan alapanyagot termel hogy ő
is ugyanúgy beleviszi a szakmai tudá át
ő megtermeli a szép alapanyagot én az én
szakmai tudásommal pedig elkészítem
belőle azt amit a
kedves vendégek látni akarnak
ízlelni akarnak kóstolni akarnak tehát
hatalmas láncfolyamat ez az egész ez
biztos hogy ez is önmagában egy komplex
folyamat és hogyha jól értettem akkor
előre felkészülsz és elszállítod ezt az
ételt ott helyben történik főzés vagy
sütés természetesen itt az olimpián úgy
történt hogy megvolt a kiállító
nagyterem de mi külön konyhát kellett
béreljünk az egész csapat mert azt elő
kell készíteni ott rengeteget kellett
dolgozni kimártásokat kellett készíteni
tehát ahhoz hogy az az artisztika munka
megállja a helyét az egész csapat egy
hatalmas konyhát kellett béreljen ahol
tudunk is dolgozni minden nap reggel
korán elkezdt a
munkát volt hogy ugye éjjel be
belementünk sőt olyan is hogy le se
feküdtünk most hogyha rólam beszélünk
akkor szombaton volt nekem az egyik
munkám vasárnap pedig a másik munkám és
pénteken érkeztünk
németországba levezetni egyszer ugye a
kollégám vezetett le egy 900 km-t
azelőtt én is egy 600-at hullafáradtan
megérkeztünk és máris fogtunk neki
dolgozni
lejárt az én számom szombaton fogtam
neki már a vasárnapi számomra azt is
rakjuk
össze vasárnap egész nap hétfőn már
segítettél a kollégádnak az ő munkájába
kedden pedig a másiknak a munkájában
segítettél tehát intenzív kemény
atmunk csapatmunkáról
beszélünk és tényleg mentálisan is
nagyon-nagyon ott kell lenni
és és és lehet hogy meg néha vannak
olyan pillanatok amikor mentálisan meg
is gyötör ez a kemény munka mert érzed
azt a hatalmas volumenű kihívást h és a
zsűrű mi alapján dönt tehát hogy van egy
esztétikai kateg elmesélted hogy az
állvány maga is fontos része a
dekorációnak maga hogyan rendezed el az
ételt de megkóstolják ezeket a a az étel
most nyilván nem a ö dekorációra
gondoltam természetesen hogyha hideg
meleg ételekről vagy
fingerfoodokról beszélünk akkor nyilván
meg is kóstolják meg is kóstolhatják de
ahhoz hogy eljussal már eleve például
táblára te neked fantázia nevet is kell
alkossál a a
munkádnak azt le kell fordíttas te
kétféle nyelven hogy a zsűri lássa hogy
tulajdonképp hogy az ami előtte van az
mi az igen mi a mi a mögöttes mondjam
úgy hogy történetre erre igen erre
nyilván tormácsot kellett
fogadjunk azt le kellett fordíttatni azt
szépen hogyha keretbe rakod figyelik az
asztalodnak az összeállítását is hogy
összhangban van-e minden kicsi apró
dologra
figyeltél-e koszosan
dolgozol-e higiénikusan
dolgozol-e minden kicsi apróságra oda
odfigyelnek h ha a versenyasztalomra
leteszek egy kávés részét mínusz pont
hühüm nem szabad ott legyen a
megvilágítástól elkezdve hogy hogyan
kommunikálod ki a munkádat afele aki ezt
ő le kell zsűrizze ezek minden kicsi
apróságra tát akkor ilyenkor kiálsz és
el is mondod ezeket a dolgokat vagy ők
figyelnek nem tehát itt most tételesen
úgy volt hogy 7 órára reggel 7 órára
kell lett készen legyünk a munkánkkal
ezért mi már ugye hajnali 4 órakor már
kezdtük el a munkánkat befejezni 5
órakor már csomagoltunk
tettük be az autóba kiszállítottuk a
helyre ahol majd ki kell szépen állítsuk
és 7 órakor mi is el kellett hagyjuk a
termet a versenytermet és akkor jött a
zsűri és 7 órától 9 óráig lezsűrizték az
egész nagytermet akinek munkája volt
értem tehát akkor te már nem voltál ott
jelen mi már nem voltunk ott tehát úgy
úgy megy a zsűrizés hogy maga a munka
megalkotója nincsen ott visont táblára
rá van tehát a benevezési listádon
szerepel a neved titulusod mit akar mit
készítte ezt lefordítva -tól z-ig tehát
mindent mindent meg kellett ezeket
tervezni e e ez olyan olyan mintogyha
ezek a zsűrik azt nézték volna hogy a
séf szellemiséget mennyire tudja az a
kompozíció átadni és minden kicsi apró
részletet figyelembe véve igen például a
sorsrészt a artisztikánál olyan gyönyörű
szép munkákat láttam én a
a világ több tájáról hát nyilván a
keletiek azok azok hatalmas művészek a
zöldséggyümölcs szobrászatban ugye a
tájfaragászat az az már megint egy olyan
szint
amit amit mi fel se tudunk érni ezért is
már a versenyen már szorólapot osztottak
hogy a tájfaragászatot válasszák-e külön
a zöldségg
gyümölcszobrászattól a tájfaragászat
ugye tájföldről jön és nekik kultúrájuk
ezt iskolába tanítják és gyakorlatilag
totálisan verhetetlenek tehát nem
született olyan ember aki egy
tájfaragómestert
őberelni tud ezért meg is kérdezték hogy
mi a versenyző véleménye hogy válasszák
a következő olimpiára válasszák szét a
tájfaragást a
zöldséggyümörcszobrászatól és nyilván az
összes szobrász azt mondta hogy igen
mert az az övéké és akkor már ezen a
versenyen szét volt választva ezen még
nem volt széttz ar nyérmet el is vitte
akkor a tájfaragó simán pers simán és
akkor a a a az ezüst és a bronz
gyakorlatilag az ami a reális hely így
így van tehát ilyen most bronzérmet
kaptál körülbelül igen de nem a zöldségg
gyümölcszobrászatban hanem a sóstészta
artisztikába sosészt a artisztikánál t
pedig úgy volt hogy ugyancsak a a
keletiek hát gyönyörű szobrokat
készítettek
sóstésztából de viszont a zsűri egyéb
más szempontot nézett sóstésztából olyan
gyönyörű szobrok alkotótak de viszont én
azt láttam illetve azt véltem felfedezni
hogy a szobrok mögött egy sablon van üüm
tehát hogy sablonra tették rá azt a
sóstésztát és onnan ól volt szépen
tényleg minden kicsi apró részlett
kidolgozva az én sóstésztám az pedig nem
sablonra készült hanem totális kicsi
apró miniatűr kézim munkából állt össze
az egész azt a tésztát begyúrni azt a
tésztát megformálni azt a tésztát
színesíteni
szárítani úgy hogy ne égjen meg
összerakni úgy az állványra hogy az
szállít ó legyen és úgy kiállítsd na
ezek elég kemény kihívások hm egy újabb
komplexitás mennyire szubjektív a zsűri
tehát amikor te nézed akkor egyet tudsz
érteni a zsűri döntéseivel most nyilván
nem a te munkádat nézem a többi munkáb
összehasonlítva uggy azért érzed hogy
milyen logika alapján dönt a zsűri és
helyesen
dönt-
például nem nem nem nem értettem meg
a zsűrinek néhány döntését amikor voltak
a a
kiértékelések
mert azon kívül például most más
kategóriába vegyük a
sajtfaragást számomra én azt mondtam
hogy az én
kollégám balog martin egy olyan gyönyörű
szép munkával és az a az a munkája az a
sajt faragása az történetet mesélt el a
a nézelődők számára és engem
rettenetesen bosszantott az hogy kevésbé
értékelték az ő munkáját mint egy egy
sima
parmezánsajtba be belefaragott motívumot
amibe gyakorlatilag azt mondja az ember
hogy ezt én is meg tudom csinálni de
balog martin kollégám ő egy olyan szép
történetet kunyhót
főzőkályhát házikót
körülötte tehát egy olyan történetet
mesélt el sajtból amit azt mondtam hogy
egy artisztika munka gyakorlatilag
legyőzött holott én úgy gondoltam hogy
ezt nem szabadott volna tehát
valahogy nem éreztem korrektnek akkor
azt a azt a kiértékelést hogy mi alapján
szavazták meg azt hogy az az sokkal
többet ér mint egy egy olyan amivel
sokkal többet van dolgozva és és sokkal
kidolgozottabb az egész j nyilván most
mondhatná a cinikus énye valakinek hogy
a saját csapattársad fele húz a szíved
de hogy a többi most eltekintve a magyar
versenyzőktől úgy úgy azért érződött
hogy jól jól dönthet a zsűri vagy
teljesen összevisszán döntöt v é csak
azt vettem észre inkább hogy rengeteg
egyforma munkát véltem felfedezni és és
most nem azért mert a kollégám de a
kollégám totálisan teljesen más
szemszögből közelítette meg a versenyt
hogy történetet mesélt el mint az hogy
egy egy csomó egyforma munkát láttam és
és mégis azok vitték el a príet tehát én
én azt mondtam hogy
összességében
részletességben és az a munka ahogy fel
volt építve számomra sokkal többet ért
nem azért mert a kollégám csinálta mert
hogyha becsuk teljesen nem tudom azt
hogy ki melyik munkát csinálja én
észreveszem azt hogy hogy melyik
munkában van sokkal jobb jobban odaadva
a munka és a tehetség és a türelem tehát
én én is különbséget tudok tenni és ezt
ezt azért ez ez egyáltalán nem tetszett
hogy hogy akkor akkor azt azt a munkát
nem úgy értékelték ahogy kellett volna
mert én azt mondtam hogy simán egy arany
aranyérmet el fog
vinni azonkívül pedig láttam nagyon
gyenge munkákat amibe se technológia se
a fények semmi nem úgy volt belevíve
mint például egyik ismerősömnek olyan
munkája volt hogy tudom hogy napokon
keresztül dolgozott folyamatosan
úgy beszél a
csokoládéról mint a gyermekéről hogy úgy
annyira imádja és szereti a munkáját és
meg voltam el lepődve azon hogy egy
olyan csokoládé vagy egy olyan
deszertmunkát értékeltek és és tételesen
az amivel ő dolgozott az kevésbé hogy
láttam hogy lehet hogy én én tényleg
láttam azt hogy az az milyen kemény
munkával állt össze és és én szerettem
volna azt hogy hogy ő egy sokkal nagyobb
eredményt érjen el mint amilyen
eredményt elért de én már azt mondom
hogy eleve egy olimpián a legesleutolsó
is első hát az biztos hogy ha valaki oda
kijut az már az már önmagában egy szűrőn
keresztül bármilyen haegy bármilyen
kategóriájú kisebb versenyre is elmész
ha már megpróbálod és elmész egy
versenyre te már alapból győztes vagy
ezt most már a harmadik történeted is ez
bizonyítja hogy három nehézséggel
szembeszállva hogyan tudtál három
különböző ajtót kinyitni és bemenni mi a
következő ajtó mi a következő kihívás
számodra
200026-ra az egyesületünk és a csapatunk
készül a világbajnokságra luxemburgba h
ez egy igazán kemény kihívás most az
egyesületünk
folyamatosan gálaesteket és
rendezvényeket
tartunk országunk különböző pontjaiban
most például a az egyik csapattársam ő
szlovák bottyán szilvia most a múlt
hétvégén náluk tartottunk egy
gálavacsorát és támogatói estet nyilván
itt nálunk székelyföldön is jövőre meg
akarjuk tartani a migála estünket és
támogatói
vacsoraestünket valószínűleg szerbiában
is lesz valószínűleg ukrajnában is lesz
mert egy-egy csapattársunk ugye egyik
szerb másik ukránmagyar üü
szlovákmagyar erdélyi magyar tehát így
van összeállva hogy a
diaszporából tehetséges szakembereket
válogatott össze varka károly séf úr és
országon ként városainkban és
környékünkön gálaesteket tartunk azért
támogatói vacsoraesteket tartunk azért
hogy az egyesületünk gyűjtsön egy kicsi
anyagi forrást ahhoz hogy kijussunk a
luxemburgi
világbajnokságra és ezáltal valamilyen
nyomot is
hagyjunk a munkásságunk által
itthon tehát hogy körülb p van szükség
ahhoz hogy ki tudjatok jutni hát
szerintem egy olyan 300€
ühüm az úgy úgy belefoglal alapanyagot
költségeket
szállást mindent és hát ez ez nem nem is
tűnik olyan soknak ahhoz képest hogy
hogy milyen volumenű eseményről van szó
hányan mentek ki és hog milyen hozadéka
van ennek
igen tehát ez az összeg ez szerintem
már ahhoz is kell hogy az
alapanyagbeszerzéshez a fuvar a szállás
a
konyhabérlés minden minden átz ég és az
hogy a hogy ha lehet ha egy mód van rá
akkor kényelemben legyünk ahhoz hogy
hogy maximálisra tudjuk tenni a a
limitet én megfutatva körülbelül egy
ennyit tippelnék egy ennyiözegre szükség
van egy utolsó területről beszélgetnék
még egy kicsit az utolsó most már azt
hiszem hogy 10
percünkbe én főleg így az elmúlt 10
évben több ilyen séfes filmet láttam úgy
az én kultúrámba így jönnek be ezek a
filmek és hogy belelátni hogy a a
konyhában milyen mi az a dinamika amiről
te is meséltél az a zaj az a dinamizmus
ami benne van ez ez több ilyen filmen
keresztül jött egy dolog viszont
felmerült a folyamatosan nekem az összes
filmben a séfek élete egy ilyen drámai
szétzúzódott elvált
egy egy egy szenvedéssel teli személyes
kapcsolatokkal teli képet mutat be a
séfekről igen igen de mi az amit látsz
így ilyen szempontból ez tényleg ez egy
egy valós vagy pedig egy drama túl
dramatizált kép amit bemutatnak kényes
témát érintünk de semmiféleképpen nem
mondanám azt hogy túl
dramatizált tények ezek hanem ezek
konkrét
tények magamról beszélve közeli
szakácskollégáimról beszélve sőt ha nem
közeli akkor távoli szakácsk
kollégáinkat azért ö meggyötörte tehát a
a magánéletünk az azért eléggé húzos
tehát én azt mondom hogy a siker fele
vezető út az nem mindig egyenes hanem
nagyon kacskaringós
és göröngyös az út a siker fele tehát
nem minden úgy van
hogy a sikerért mi keményen dolgoztunk
és rengeteg mindent fel kellett adjunk
igen rengeteg szakács és séf elvált én
azt én mindig azt mondtam hogy sikeres
férfi mellett
egy patika stabil nő áll és hiszem ezt
és ezt
hiszem akkor lehetséges az hogy egy
egészséges párkapcsolatot fenn tudj
tartani vagy pedig egyszerűen hogyha ezt
a szakmát választod akkor készülj fel
arra hogy hogy nem lesz egy stabil
párkapcsolatod lehet stabil
párkapcsolatot de ez nyilván ugye ez két
emberen múlik az egész de hát hogyha a
te pár árod tiszteli és becsüli azt amit
te csinálsz és amit képviselsz és
elfogad úgy hogy te ezzel foglalkozol
akkor ő elfogadja azt is hogy néha a
családi ünnepekről te
hiányzol de te azért hiányzol mert éppen
másnak kell örömet szerezé üüm ugye
nyilván
most egy kezdő szakács aki most fog bele
a szakmájába és még tegyük fel nincsen
stabil párkapcsolata mit üzennél ennek a
személynek hogy mire szám tson így a a
szakmája során hogyan válasszon párt
mire készítse fel a párját hogyha már
tegyük fel már tehát hogyha én azt
mondanám annak az illetőnek hogyha te
maximalista vagy és nagyon akarod ezt a
szakmát és nem félvárul akarod venni
akkor a párodat arra készíts fel hogy
támogasson a te szakmai utadban mert ez
utána megköszöni saját magát tehát a a
párkapcsolat az az megint csak olyan
hogy ez ebből kifolyólag most ha azt
vesszük hogy a a szakácsoknak nehéz mert
ünnepeken dolgoznak akkor meg hány meg
hány olyan szakma van ahol igenis
ünnepeken dolgoznak vegyük csak a
kereskedelmet az emberek ahhoz hogy
otthon egy családba tudjanak egy
terített asztal mellett étkezni ahhoz a
kereskedők a kereskedelemben dolgozók
gyakorlatilag az időt el kell vegyék a
családtól tehát hatalmas tisztelet jár
feléjük és nyilván hogy
hogy a a
párkapcsolatiban lévő személyek most
tételezzük fel az én társam ha nem
támogat úgy érzem
hogy hogy nem tudnék én olyan maximumra
törni hogyha ő nincsen mellettem és azt
mondja hogy szívvel llekkel csinál tehát
egy pár kapcsolatban szerintem nagyon
fontos a társad hogy ő támogasson ha ez
nincsen meg akkor akkor sajnos tényleg
most megkaptad ezt a társat igen teljes
mértékben úgy érzem és tényleg tévéktől
elkezdve mindenhol az jön le hogy a a
szakácsok vagy elváltak vagy nyilván
vendéglátásb én is ismerek rengeteg
olyan személyt aki al
alkoholizmussal küzd drogokkal küzd
álmatlansággal küzd egészségtelen
életmódot él de nyilván én most is azt
mondom hogy ez hogyha te a te életedben
stabil párkapcsolat van majdnem ez nem
engedi mert ott van a társad és látja
azt amikor te úgy érzed hogy nem bírod ő
kell adja azt a löketet
hogy csináljad és vidd tovább mert ez a
te utad és ne engedjen se droghoz se
italhoz
tudjál nyugodtan aludni társai a
párkapcsolatod nagyon-nagyon fontos
kiegészítő része szerintem ahhoz hogy te
sikeres legyél a stabil
párkapcsolat azt hiszem ez egy nagyon jó
pont megálljunk és nagyon köszönöm neked
hogy bevezettél a séfek világába hogy
mennyire komplex is valójában amit
csinálsz hogy egyszerre kell
szakemberként hely helytálj egyszerre
kell ilyen atyai lélekkel összefogd a
csapatot bátorítsd meg érezd a csapatot
egyszerre kell egy pénzügyi szakember
legyél egyszerre kell érts a az ételek
mitől válnak egészségessé és egyszerre
kell igazábó igazából azt is elmondhatom
hogy ezen idő alatt mindennek csak a
töredékét tudtuk átbeszélni de nyilván
hogy hogy rengeteg témát lehet még
ezenkívül érinteni tehát milliómillió
tém át hogyha minden kicsi apró témát
pontokra lebontunk akkor akkor még
millió dolgot tudunk érinteni én én azt
mondom összességében az egész
beszélgetésünket összefoglalva én
rengeteg embernek hálával tartozom
hálával tartozom a főnökeimnek hálával
tartozom a gyerekeimnek hálával tartozom
a szüleimnek testvéremnek
párkapcsolatomnak szeretteimnek ahhoz
hogy most ott vagyok ahol vagyok tehát
ez ez még egyszer egy mértéktelen
tisztelet és alázat az emberek fele és
aki engem ismer az tudja hogy én ilyen
vagyok én szeretek adni és szeretek
megköszönni is ezt tudom tanúsítani
köszönöm szépen domi hogy itt voltál én
köszönöm szépen szabolcsa a meghívást
öröm volt beszélgetni egy kicsit a
szakmáról ha tetszett ez a műsor akkor
iratkozz fel kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel
tudsz támogatni minket köszönjük a
vckker kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre